nosotros empezamos a escuchar rap en la
década de los 90 en el barrio gran wish
de medellín justo en una época difícil
lo más patas arribas que está creo yo
complicada y poco tolerante por no decir
que violenta y encontramos que la música
se convirtió en esta vía escape la única
manera de nosotros aislarnos conocer lo
que no queríamos ver
en ese tiempo recuerdo a todos los
amigos de nosotros hablar de conseguir
una moto y ser el duro del barrio
algunos y tener las mujeres y tener
plata y lo que nosotros empezamos a
llamar el camino corto porque no quiere
decir que ese camino corto sea fácil es
corto porque todos los parte los que se
metieron en eso la mayoría ya no están
entonces nosotros nos dimos cuenta que
nosotros sólo queríamos hacer canciones
queríamos sacar la cara por otro lado no
queríamos ser algo que nos obligaba de
cierta manera la situación y empezamos a
transformar todo como a quitarnos el
prejuicio queríamos que socialmente o
culturalmente nos miraran como una
agrupación de música con un talento para
algo la música se convirtió con la
universidad de nosotros en estudiar en
desarrollar un arte una habilidad para
algo nunca quisimos el amarillismo con
que en un tiempo empezamos a hablar los
raperos como de
a los marginados y los que no tienen de
pronto muchos recursos y todo eso porque
siento que la gente oa veces los medios
nos llamaba para ella amarillismo como
matar un rapero y eso es más importante
que cualquier cosa sí o no pero cuando
un rapero tenía talento de pronto no era
una cosa para publicar nosotros nos
preocupamos por lo menos para que
tuvieran la tensión puesta nosotros por
el talento la habilidad que habíamos
desarrollado en algo y nos dedicamos
sólo a estudiar cómo ha cerrado cómo
escribir canciones y cómo mejorar cada
día lo que nosotros queríamos mostrarle
a la gente que era el talento que había
en los barrios que no sólo había lo que
todo el mundo siempre pensaba entonces
empieza el proceso de alcohólicos hacer
conciertos y de ganarse como un nombre
en la calle vendiendo discos mano a mano
y buscando y tocando puertas como como
para que la gente escuchara que la coral
a la idea de nosotros y empezamos el
proceso que llamamos nosotros nadar
contracorriente porque sentíamos que
todo está en contra de nosotros no había
nada en ese momento que estuviera a
favor de toda la música que está sonando
en radio era todo lo contrario que
nosotros hacíamos lo que la gente
apoyaba no era lo que nosotros
estábamos haciendo y empezamos a lidiar
con los prejuicios que hasta el sol de
hoy yo creo que se siguen viendo así sea
menos todavía la gente cree que un
rapero ahí va a hablar ese marihuanero y
de uno hermano 2017 y todavía la gente
cree que la marihuana es exclusiva de
los raperos
pues hay raperos quienes fuman para que
nos vayamos ahí como culturalmente hay
todavía un prejuicio que nos persigue no
nosotros sino la gente que tiene esos
prejuicios como carga con ellos
empezamos a nadar contracorriente
empieza la frase de mi madre me dijo
porque las madres son las primeras que
así no te lo digan quieren tener un hijo
universitario doctor o abogado que no
está mal pero resulta que nosotros no
éramos ninguna de las anteriores ni
queríamos dar ninguna de las anteriores
y empezamos a notar a lidiar con esos
prejuicios como la vez que mi mamá me
dijo como que alguien cercano a la
familia que estaba en malos pasos y que
murió en su ley le había hecho un
comentario que hacía gambeta rapeando y
que porque él había dado por meter ese
hombre de conseguir un trabajo
y de uno es él el que necesitaba que
alguien le dijera que iba en el mal
camino a tiempo y nadie se lo dijo pero
es más importante creer que uno está
como en un mal camino o que hacer música
o dedicarse a esto está mal y no va para
ningún lado nadie te dice cómo crear por
lo menos en esa época nadie te decía
cómo crear tu propia empresa oas o hacer
lo tuyo no siempre era cómo hacerlo para
para otro trabaja para otro es lo que
nosotros llamamos nadar contracorriente
en el proceso de haber hecho como todo
lo posible o hasta lo imposible para que
el grupo creciera
nos empezó a ir bien digámoslo así
empezamos a tener un reconocimiento y ya
tener difusión como como por lo que
nosotros consideramos que ya había
logrado tanto como vendiendo discos mano
a mano y todo ese asunto y recuerdo que
ya hemos hecho varios conciertos
importantes y nunca habíamos tocado en
el barrio nosotros en aranjuez y
decidimos hacer un concierto en aranjuez
era como una deuda que teníamos tenemos
un breve susto porque dicen que nadie es
profeta en su tierra y decidimos hacer
este concierto
no importaba el resultado lo hicimos y
se quedó gente por fuera del gentío que
fue nosotros estamos felices de poder
devolver como de cierta manera el barrio
algo de lo que nosotros hayamos
aprendido ahí mismo y era otra otra
manera de asumir la vida
el caso es que salimos de ese concierto
a celebrar a la casa de castro como ve
como el triunfo y recuerdo que ese día
hubo una pelea en la que un amigo
terminó metido y nosotros por defender
el amigo recibimos unas puñaladas ese
día y eso no se me olvida nunca como que
es una manera de como un pellizco como
una manera de decirte que no es inmortal
y que por mucho que estés metido en otro
cuento pacífico y lo que sea la realidad
te puede tocar algo no necesitas hacer
nada más los paquetes sellados entonces
nos sentíamos un poco indignados
nosotros de que eso no era por lo que
nosotros estábamos ahí pero tampoco
queríamos como quedar como los renegado
eso se puede haber vuelto un problema
porque llegaba la gente a decirte que si
había que cobrar venganza y que si había
que defendernos y todo que nosotros
defendimos de la única manera que
nosotros aprendimos lo que hicimos y es
haciendo música son de nuestro único
fuente o nuestro único fuente que
queremos ligar con todo el mundo
entonces hicimos una canción que se
llama anestesia local y esta canción
narra los dos episodios de cómo puedes
pasar de la felicidad a la tristeza de
un momento a otro sí o no
esa canción siento yo que marcó un antes
y un después como en la historia de
nosotros por qué
siento que la manera en que la gente lo
tomo o respaldó la canción como si
hubiéramos hecho un reggaeton para una
cosa
la gente la cantaba en los conciertos a
romperse la garganta y eso que recordó
que iba tarde para la casa en el mismo
barrio y desde una esquina o más negrita
aranjuez state of mind y miro yo y era
un man que ya había amanecido ahí como
tomando de los chorros y cuando reparo
bien era un lo que llaman los duros del
barrio los parceros que cuidan por ahí
un man que toda la vía aminoró nunca me
paro libro que ni sabía cómo me decía ni
cómo me llamó ni a qué me dedicaba y
ahora por esta canción que no sé cómo la
escucho ni cómo le llegó a semana los
odios yo me reconocía y se sentía yo
creo que parte de yo fue a contar a los
parceros y la manera en que todos
asumimos eso era como
nos pusimos a la madre como vamos poner
en los zapatos del otro y nos ponemos a
pensar en semana en muchos manes que
conocemos miles de historias de gente
que es muy talentosa y a veces la
necesidad o las ansias de conseguir algo
los ha metido en algo que luego no tiene
realidad lo malo no es justificable pero
si sé yo que mucha gente los barros
dibujantes manes que pintan man este
escritor editó a veces se han perdido y
ya ha quedado sin contar su historia
porque no tuvieron las herramientas a
veces para hacer las cosas estamos las
otras de nosotros en un ensayo en
marinilla con una banda llegó un parcero
con un saxofón
nosotros siempre hemos hablado que nos
parece un instrumento muy bonito y nos
gustaría algún día aprender a tocar
saxofón
de mi ignorancia le digo cuánto vale el
saxofón en ella parte 5 millones
quiero que note lo bueno de lo bueno te
digo yo parece que yo ella se vale 500
mil pesos y 5 millones de manuel ya como
con su cara como así nos toca y eso es
un platal ya entonces me vuelvo yo lo
que estamos hablando de ponerse en los
zapatos del otro ojalá un arma o una
bala aunque ya valiera una millonada lo
vienes a un montón de plata para que la
gente le costará demasiado adquirirlo es
así quisiera porque hay una brecha
demasiado grande entre conseguir un arma
en un barrio cualquier barrio en
medellín a conseguir un instrumento un
arma te la pueden hasta alquilar yo creo
juegan el price 300 mil pesos cualquier
cierro hechizo por un instrumento sigue
valiendo lo que vales yo no no digo que
no hayan otras posibilidades porque
ahora hay mucho más que en esa época
pero sigo diciendo que la brecha es
demasiado grande nadie de por sí tiene
una guitarra un sacrificio yo te lo
presto para que lo hagas te siento yo
que si hay unas desventajas a veces y
todo eso solo se combaten con creo yo
como con más guerra no hay muchas
opciones a veces para que esos pelados
cada vez tienen que llegar a ellos
demostrarle que hay otras opciones que
no todo es así tan a las carreras ni a
tirarse a matar entonces siento yo que
una canción como anestesia local mostró
la manera de nosotros volverlo malo algo
bueno para transformar y no quedarse con
lo malo ni agrandar la bola de lo malo
sino en lo bueno y en tramos como en un
tiempo de decir bueno llegó la hora de
cambiar el chip a la gente y empezamos a
ver cómo hasta el cerebro ya nos quería
ya todos los que nos veían como unos
vagos
ahora les gustaba porque siento yo que
hay una frase que dice que sin milagros
no hay fe y nosotros ya habíamos hecho
el milagro y habíamos dicho a la gente
esto somos capaz de hacer con o sin
ayuda entonces empiezan a llegar los
prelados del barrio orgulloso de que
alcohólicos y los demás grupos que están
haciendo rap sacando la cara salen de
allá empiezan a ser sus propios
proyectos ya creer que es viable hacerlo
empieza tu mamá no ver que que era de
bajo si es y hermanas que no tenían ni
siquiera claro para dónde vida entonces
ya no había vergüenza ajena sino un
orgullo ajeno una un montón de gente
feliz deseándote lo mejor porque de
cierta manera era lo que lo que se les
había entregado un montón de cosas que
la gente tenía que apropiarse y sentir
que eran propias nosotros siempre
decimos que el rap o la música en
general no se ha dado más de lo que
nosotros le habíamos pedido
de cierta manera esperábamos
hemos tenido la posibilidad de d
de salir a ciudades donde jamás
pensábamos llevar público para nosotros
o ciudades en las que jamás si no
hubiera sido por la música hubiéramos
salido no hay peces es como encerrado en
su burbuja en su barrio y esto le abre a
uno como el mundo hemos ido
prácticamente por todo colombia
mostrando lo que hacemos y no solo lo
que hacemos sino el mensaje que tenemos
hemos salido del país a lo mismo a
decirle a la gente cómo viven los
pelados acá como salimos adelante solo a
punta de lo que aprendemos o nos metemos
en la cabeza de cierta manera antes para
mí era impensable llenar un concierto
con algo que no fuera bailable o algo
que dijera la verdad como que con el
tiempo cada vez la música es menos
mensajes cada vez es menos está diciendo
algo nosotros metimos en la película más
física del mundo de tratar de poner
hablar a la gente o de mover la cabeza
diciendo la verdad que mucha gente no
quiere oír entonces hace poco en agosto
tuvimos la oportunidad de ser la portada
de rolling stones y para nosotros esta
foto significa mucho porque la hizo
nuestro hermano julián gaviria y es
exactamente en el barrio del que les
estamos hablando
aranjuez que es donde salió todo donde
hay un montón de gente talentosa y un
montón de gente que vive tan la mañana
es de barrio que a veces no quisiera ni
siquiera salir al mar ni a conocer nada
a todo el mundo se siente que está en su
burbuja y para nosotros esto representa
una manera de decir a la gente hasta qué
punto puede llegar a uno cuando nadie le
saca de la cabeza esa idea de que lo que
uno hace lo puede llegar a cabo como sea
si tiene paciencia y se escoge el camino
más largo que es en donde más se aprende
otra cosa que decimos es que todo el
mundo necesita de la música a veces hay
gente que actúa como como si eso no
fuera así la gente escucha música
palabra el carro para barrer para
trapear a la fiesta le ponen música pero
si el hijo dice que quiere ser músico el
problema
si sus hijos si tienen hijos o hijas que
eran algún día ser músico hay que
apoyarlo eso yo siento que contribuyen
más que cualquier otra cosa no estoy
quitándole méritos a las otras
profesiones para siento que por ejemplo
el artista le exigen ser exitosa un
artista legend bueno si sos artista
dónde está tu carro y tu fama y por qué
seguir viviendo en el agua si tu mujer
es como un estereotipo raro cuando el
éxito así suena muy hippie sigue siendo
contarle a mis nietos amigos que yo fui
feliz y escogí lo que quería hacer y lo
saque a flote con mis partes con un
montón gente gente que quería soñar con
eso
estamos segurísimos que cuando
trabajamos en una empresa en trabajos
que ni queríamos nadie nos preguntó que
si estábamos bien o mal nadie nos dijo
que si estábamos aburridos o no o que si
era lo que queríamos porque es como el
protocolo como el libreto lo que todo el
mundo sabe que se puede o que se debe de
hacer y nosotros estábamos dispuestos a
llevarle la contraria a tu hueso para
finalizar finalizamos con con la frase
que de cierta manera define mucho y es
el barrio está lleno de trampas y atajos
nosotros escogimos el camino más largo
ahora todos pueden transitar los muchas
gracias